[MUSIC PLAYING]
MO FONG: Hi.
Hi.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
My name is Mo Fong.
This is Randy Reyes.
And we are here to help you--
go up to the stage,
we've been told.
OK.
To the stage.
Better?
OK.
Awesome.
Hi.
I'm Mo Fong.
And I'm a director for
K-12 education outreach
here at Google.
And it is my honor
to be here to host
this panel of national leaders
and experts and race experts
as well to talk about Bamboo
Ceilings, Minority Myths,
and also just to help educate
around the Asian community.
So this has been a
long time in coming.
I've been at Google for 10
years, seven in finance,
three in comps, and
now in engineering,
doing education work.
And so I've seen this
community evolve over time.
And it's wonderful
to see that we are
all part of this conversation.
This is part of the
Decoding Race series
which the Race At Google
team has been preparing
for over the last few quarters.
There have been nine
different panels
talking about various aspects
around the race discussion.
And so this is the first
time that the Asian community
has come together to talk
about what it means for us.
I'm particularly excited
about this panel,
not just because
I'm Asian American
but because this is a community
of people who really want
to understand and educate
one another about how we can
collectively improve
relationships across the aisle,
across different groups, so that
we can make progress together.
My first experience with race
was when I was really young.
I immigrated from
Taiwan when I was five.
And I literally was the only
Asian, other than my sister,
in our elementary
school in Michigan.
And so to feel like an
outlier in those situations,
I mean I think it was really
early on that I realized
gosh one of us doesn't
look like the other
and what does that mean.
And then my parents
came to California
and there was a
lot more diversity.
And then I started
teaching high school.
And it was interesting.
I've had these conversations
with my high school students
as well.
And I taught in
Cupertino at Monte Vista.
And it was about
60% Asian back then.
I think it's now up
to like 70% Asian.
And the students will
be the first to tell you
Asia is not a country.
There are a lot of
different types of Asians.
We don't all experience
the same things.
And so they were trying
to educate each other
about their cultures as well.
So I'm hoping some of
that will come out today.
But definitely, welcome
all the conversations
we're going to be having.
So it's a dialogue.
And I hope this dialogue
continues even after today.
So thank you all
again for being here.
And I'm going to
turn it over to Randy
to talk to you about the panel.
RANDY REYES: Hi.
Thanks, Mo.
Good morning, everybody.
I'm Randy Reyes from
the Diversity Team.
I'm the client adviser for
the Asian Google network,
the Filipino Google network,
the Indus Google network,
and the Google American
Indian network.
And I'm also part of the
large planning team that
helped put this panel together.
I'm personally excited
about this particular panel
and our panelists,
because I feel
like in the context of
race, a lot of the times,
Asian gets overlooked.
And when it's actually
included in the conversation,
the diversity that exists
within our Asian category
isn't necessarily
unpacked or talked about.
So I'm super excited to hear
the conversation and what's
to emerge.
Before I passed it
over to Lorrie Ma, who
is our awesome moderator, as
well as to the wonderful panel,
I have four reminders
for you all.
The first is that
it's being recorded.
The second, it's
going on YouTube.
The third, do not post to social
media until it goes public.
And the last is if you guys
have questions for the panel,
those on live stream or people
sitting in the audience that
don't feel comfortable going to
the mic, go/decodingrace-dory,
D-O-R-Y, is where you
can post questions.
And with that, I'll pass
it to Laurie, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
LORRIE MA: Hi, guys.
My name is Lorrie.
And for my day job, I am a
program manager in privacy
here.
And as my 20%, or as some
people like to say 150%,
I am the co-lead for
Asian Google network.
And so I am very excited to be
moderating this panel today.
And instead of reading
off their bios, which
I'm sure you guys have all
received in the multiple emails
that we sent out,
I would actually
love the panelists to
introduce themselves.
So I will start from my right.
QUYEN DINH: Good
morning, everyone.
Is this working?
Great.
My name is Quyen Dinh.
I am from San Jose.
So I grew up in the Bay Area.
I went to Cal for my undergrad.
And I'm currently the
Executive Director
of SEARAC, the Southeast
Asia Resource Action Center.
We're based in Washington DC
with an office in Sacramento,
California.
And I'm so excited
to be here today.
Thank you.
VALARIE KAUR: Hi, everybody.
My name is Valarie Kaur.
I am a Sikh American.
I'm a South Asian
American activist.
I've been doing this
work for about 15 years
as a civil rights lawyer,
filmmaker, organizer.
Right now I run something called
the Revolutionary Love Project
at USC to equip people to
fight for social justice
through the ethic of love.
PHIL YU: Hi, everybody.
Good morning.
My name is Phil Yu.
I run a blog called
Angry Asian Man which
is a blog that covers Asian
American issues, news,
perspectives, pop
culture, politics.
I've been running it for 16
years, which is like insane.
I am glad to be back in the Bay.
I grew up in Sunnyvale.
Went to Homestead High School.
My folks still live here.
So it's good to be back.
Thanks.
LORRIE MA: All right.
Let's give our panelists
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So without further ado, let's
get the conversation started.
And just a reminder, what
we're trying to do here
is to have healthy
dialogue around race.
And something that's,
for some reason,
fairly difficult for Asians.
So you know when you think
about Asian, none of us
really identify
ourselves as Asian.
You know, I don't go
around saying I am Asian.
I go around saying I am Chinese.
So we inherently
have this problem
where Asian is just made up
of so many different things
that race affects
us very differently.
So I want to pose this question
to our panelists of when
did you realize that
race was a thing for you?
And how did it affect you?
Anyone feel free to start?
PHIL YU: I guess I can start.
So I'm Korean American.
My parents immigrated
from Korea in the '70s.
I grew up here in the Bay.
And things are like--
there's like there's
hella Asians in the Bay now.
But when I was growing up,
there were quite a few as well.
It was growing.
But there weren't as many
Koreans where I was growing up.
It's very different now.
But I think for the most part,
most of my life growing up I
mean, I considered
myself Korean American.
I knew I was Asian.
When you looked
like this, people
assume that you are Asian.
But it was kind of just like
a category you checked off.
I was, for the most,
I was Korean American
and whatever that means.
For me, I actually went to
college at Northwestern.
And being plucked from the
Bay Area to the Midwest
was a bit of a
culture shock for me.
A lot of things I took
for granted in terms
of being with community.
Stuff that I hadn't
really thought about
before in terms of
being with a larger
Asian American community.
It suddenly became
very obvious to me
the things that I took for
granted in terms of the way
you interact with one another.
And I look very different
from the people in my classes,
You and my interests are,
and what I grew up with,
these are very sort of
typical things I think.
So it was a bit
of culture shock.
And then the other thing was
that I took Asian American
Studies courses in college,
which was just like for me,
it was the beginning of a
lot of different things.
It was a wake up call
in terms of my adapting
Asian American as a
political identity.
Not just something
that I checked off,
but something I purposely
wore on my sleeve.
So now when people ask me--
I mean like it's clear
I'm like I'm Asian.
But I'm usually asked, I'm
usually I'm Asian American.
And then the other identity
is Korean American.
But as a political identity,
what I wear on my sleeve,
it's definitely Asian American.
And it's very purposeful
when I say that.
Because I mean we've
already touched upon this,
but like I think a lot
of people don't realize
they're Asian until
they get to like to--
in Asia, nobody really
considers themselves Asian.
You're your own
whatever nationality
where ever you come from.
But when you come to
America, and a lot of people
immigrate here, and suddenly
like this is thrust upon you.
You're Asian whether
you like it or not.
And so however you embrace
that, it's up to you.
So when you get
here, a lot of people
are still resistant to
the idea of being Asian.
But I think that as
an organizing tool,
Asian is a super inconvenient
convenient unwieldy term
for a lot of different groups
and people, but very necessary.
And so that's sort of, at
least from the beginning
of my journey in college
when I sort of became aware
as my history and my
identity, I think,
where I wanted to-
and I decided--
that's the thing.
Being Asian, I think is Asian
American, it's an opt in.
It's an opt in identity.
You have to opt in to
being Asian American.
You can go on being Chinese
American, Korean American,
or whatever.
But I think that you have to
choose to be Asian American.
VALARIE KAUR: Well, race
first came alive to me
through the stories
I grew up with.
So my grandfather sailed on a
Japanese steamship, the Nippon
Maru, across the
Pacific Ocean in 1913.
He arrived in San Francisco.
He was one of the first early
pioneers from South Asia.
He was a Sikh American
wearing a turban and beard.
And immigration officials
saw him on Angel Island
and immediately
incarcerated him.
Said there was no need for
his class of labor here.
And I actually cited prejudice
against his class of laborer
for exhibiting
prejudice against him.
So he was incarcerated
for months on end.
And it was a white
lawyer, Henry Marshall,
who released him on a
writ of habeas corpus
on Christmas Eve 1913.
My grandfather made
his way down the valley
and he settled in Clovis,
which is near Fresno,
just a few hours south of here.
And I think something
about understanding the way
that that act of solidarity
set him free showed him what
it meant to be an American.
So when his Japanese
American neighbors were then
rounded up and taken
to concentration camps
during World War II,
he was one of the few
who hooked up his
horse and buggy
and traveled to the deserts of
post in Arizona to visit them.
He looks after
their farms and made
sure they were safe
for when they returned.
And so, growing up
with these stories,
we still had like that piece of
petrified rock my grandfather
found on that camp
sitting on our fireplace.
So growing up with
these stories,
I understood, just like
as Phil has mentioned,
that growing up as Asian
American is an opt in.
That my grandfather showed
me that saying that you're
Asian American is actually
an act of solidarity,
that I will stand
with you brother,
I will stand with you sister,
even if we are read differently
by the dominant culture.
We are in this together.
I think race is a construct.
But it's important
to think of it
as a cage that determines
how other people see us
and how the state treats us.
And so when my grandfather first
arrived, the cage we were under
was Hindu.
And that wasn't even
a racial category.
It was a religious
identification
that didn't even align with my
grandfather's Sikh identity.
So we were called Hindus
when we first arrived.
And then on census
forms, Hindus or other.
And then under the
Asian Exclusion Acts,
we, along with our Chinese,
Japanese American brothers
and sisters were not allowed
to become citizens because we
weren't Caucasian or white.
We weren't allowed to own land.
And we weren't allowed
to return to this country
if we ever left.
There was a counterpart of my
grandfather's, Bhagat Singh
Thind, who, in 1923, took a
case all the way to the Supreme
Court arguing that actually
South Asian American are
Caucasian.
And the Supreme Court said,
well, certainly our founders
did not mean for you to
be on the same platform
as a white Scandinavian,
a blond Scandinavian.
And so you are denied
citizenship along
with other Asian Americans.
So see how the concept of race
has shifted over the time.
And so growing up
with these stories,
I understood that this is
something that's imposed on us.
That it's a cage that
we are operating under.
I, myself, did not
experience it until I
was a kid in elementary school.
I was playing house
in the school yard
on my knees pretending to be a
baby, when a little boy ran up
to me and said get
up you black dog.
So here we are, a
family who's been called
Hindu, other, Caucasian,
Asian, and now blackness
is something we have taken
on as the word, the N-word,
and then Sand-N-word has
now been thrust upon us.
I did not understand the
danger and the violence
that racial constructs can
wield in our communities
until September 11th.
I was a 20-year-old college kid.
I was here at Stanford.
In the wake of the
terrorist attacks,
hate violence erupted on city
streets across this country.
Four days later,
Balbir Singh Sodhi,
who was a Sikh American
man, who was standing
in front of his store
in Mesa, Arizona
when a man wheeled around the
corner and shot him four times,
called himself a patriot
when he was arrested.
Balbir Uncle was
someone my family knew.
So I felt as though an
uncle had been murdered.
And his murder barely
made the evening news.
This was before Google.
This was before
Facebook, before YouTube,
before Twitter, before we had
any modes of communication.
And so the desperation
of understanding
that a century of
being in this country,
we were still being read as
perpetually foreign, and now,
and now, as terrorist.
Because what's happened in
the years since September 11th
is that a new racial
category has been formed,
the racial category of
the Muslim terrorist.
And Muslims are in that
category, brown Muslims,
black Muslims, Sikh Indians,
white Sikhs, Arab Christians,
Latinos with beards,
Native Americans
have been killed in the name of
going back to their country out
of Islamophobia.
So this construct now is so
enormous that it cages so many
of us.
And my heartbreak
at this moment is
that I thought that Balbir
Uncle's murder may turn me
into an activist for 15 years.
Every film, every lawsuit,
every social media campaign,
I thought we were making
the country a safer
place for the next generation.
My son is born.
He's two years old.
And he's growing
up now in an era
that the Southern Poverty
Law Center has called
the era of enormous rage.
Hate crimes are
skyrocketing once again,
rivaling the numbers
that we saw after 9/11.
Hate groups have
increased in this country.
Anti-Muslim hate groups have
tripled in the last year.
And the current
president is releasing
an onslaught of executive
orders that punish our people.
I'm raising a brown
boy who may someday
wear a turban as part of
his faith in a country that
is more dangerous than
the one that I was given,
even more dangerous than the
one that my grandfather arrived
in a century ago.
So race is construct.
Race is cage.
And we don't understand
the danger of race
until we listen to
one another's stories,
until we understand that
Srinivas Kuchibhotla who
was murdered on February
22nd, Indian American, told
to go back to his country, is
not just a foreigner, not just
an engineer immigrant.
He's a brother.
He's a fellow American.
The Sikh American who
was shot in Washington
fixing his car in
his own driveway
was told to go back to
his country on March 3rd.
He is a brother.
But every time we hear a news
of ongoing violence, the one
thing that is giving me hope is
that there are millions of us--
we're having conversations
like this, right?
There are millions of us now
who are politically awakened
in ways that we haven't before.
I feel like we've been
fighting this fight alone
for 15 years, 16 years, right?
If all of you,
especially those who
are in positions of
relative privilege
can join us in this
fight, can show up,
can exercise your voice
online and on the ground,
then perhaps we can start
to come out from these cages
and turn these cages into
platforms of solidarity.
Thank you for inviting me
here to share this with you.
LORRIE MA: So I want to--
before Quyen gets to go--
I want to touch upon that a
little bit because I think,
Phil, you mentioned that you
sort of like Asian American
is a political
identity of yours.
And in this era, we're
getting sort of more active.
But why is it so hard for Asian
Americans in terms of this race
conversation?
Like why is activism
so difficult?
Why do you think that is?
QUYEN DINH: I really believe
that all politics is personal.
And the power of
moving beyond that cage
and really making this decision
to claim your identity,
that I am Vietnamese
American I am Asian American.
I am a woman of color.
Those things are not separate.
They are all part of who I am.
They are all part of my legacy.
They are all part of
the pain and the trauma
that my parents endured
as survivors of war
from the Vietnam War, as
warriors far, far beyond when
we came here to
the United States.
And oftentimes, I reflect on
how much privilege is required
to have this conversation.
Because if it weren't for UC
Berkeley and my Asian American
Studies classes, I would
have not had this framework
to understand race.
I would not have had the
framework to understand
how I am part of a historical
legacy of folks telling me
who I am versus me
saying this is who I am
and claiming that as
self-determination for myself
and for my community.
And I really do agree that that
is the reason why these very
personal conversations and
dialogues about how we are
impacted by race is so critical
to that self-awareness, that
politicization in being able
to have a conversation that
is really rooted in
understanding who you are
and why you're here.
And that is tremendous power
that we bring as new Americans
to this country, redefining
what this country is.
LORRIE MA: Phil, you looked
like you had something to say?
PHIL YU: To answer
your question about why
is it so hard for Asian
Americans to become active,
I suppose.
I always say it's
like you can get
Asians so hyped up about a new
kind of food or new restaurant.
But like it's so
hard to make them
give a shit about everything
in terms of really
when it comes to
sort of speaking out
about hate crimes and justice.
There's an expectation
imposed on us
that we're going to be the ones
who are going to be silent.
We're going to be
the ones who are
to keep our heads down, be the
good minorities, and not say.
Even when it's well within
our right to do, so even when
we should.
We should absolutely you
know kick down chairs,
kick down walls, and like
say something, stand up.
And I think that
there is so much--
a lot of our families
are immigrants.
And they sacrificed so much
to get here the first place.
It is to speak out,
to say something,
to make yourself
vulnerable in that way,
it would seem contrary
to all the things--
it would disrespect
all the sacrifices
that were made to get here.
But I do think that
not saying anything
is disrespectful to all
the sacrifices, and all
the challenges,
and all the things
that we had to
overcome to get here.
And I think it's
just plain easier
to try to sink in, try to blend
in, and lay back on privilege,
on this degree of privilege
that we have in this country.
Sometimes it's just easier
to stay silent, you know?
VALARIE KAUR: I want to
pick up on that because I've
spent a lot of time with
Japanese American in Fresno who
are now grandparents
and remembering
what it was like to be interned
in those concentration camps.
And Marion Masada, one of them--
who has taught me to call
them concentration camps
because that's what they were--
has shared with me that
for many years after--
she was a little girl when she
was put in those camps with her
family--
and for many years
after their release,
her parents didn't speak out.
She didn't speak out.
And she likened it
to an act of incest.
That here was a
nation that we had
loved that committed an
act of such violation
that there was confusion
and an inability
to put language to the
violation that had taken place.
And so few stood
up for them then.
So she turns to me
and says, Valarie, I
will stand up for you now.
What's giving me hope is that
the kind of courage that's
required to stand
up to injustice
means standing up
to state violence.
We know that every time
the US government targets
a particular community, not
for not for what they've done,
but for who they are, it
emboldens ordinary people
to act on biases within them
and target those communities.
So every time we see the state
punish particular communities
through detentions,
deportations, surveillance,
threats of torture,
we see hate crimes
against those communities go up.
We've seen since 9/11.
We saw it since World War II.
And that means that if
we, as Asian Americans,
are going to stand up to try
to make our community safer,
it means speaking
truth to power.
Right?
Muslim Ban 2.0 is coming down
tomorrow, everybody, March 16.
It's happening tomorrow.
I know I am bracing for more
violence against my people.
Not only the refugees and the
immigrants whose lives are now,
and futures are now
going to be in jeopardy,
but here in our
country Americans,
children in schoolyards, I
am worried for their safety.
They're worried for
their own safety.
Every week I'm at a
different college campus.
I just got back from University
of Illinois Urbana-Champaign.
And the students came up to
me with heartbreaking stories
of bullying, of racial violence,
of even sexual violence,
their inability to
make sense of it.
These are not captured
by hate crime statistics.
The hate crimes are just
the tip of the iceberg.
What remains invisible
beneath the surface
is what it feels like to live
in a climate of hate and fear.
And we have a new generation
rising up like that.
Right?
They don't remember what it
was like before 9/11, Phil.
We do.
We have that like moral
resource, but they don't.
The shadow of 9/11
is so long, people
don't even realize we're
standing in the shadow.
And so what it takes is courage
to stand up to state violence.
And this is why you naming
warrior hood I think
is like a sister yes.
Like me standing with
you was warrior sister.
Because I think for Asian
American communities,
we inherit traditions
that we think
we're just supposed to
preserve and interpret
as our parents did and pass on.
But actually, our religious,
our cultural heritages,
they are living.
They are alive and it's up
to us to reinterpret them
for a new time.
And so my call
right now is I want
a new generation of Sikh and
South Asian and Asian American
activists to rise
up as warriors.
And the story tells the
story of Mai Bhago who
was the first Sikh woman warrior
in the 17th century in South
Asia.
The story goes there
were 40 soldiers who
abandoned their post
during a great battle.
They came back to the village.
They said the fight is too hard,
we can't go back out there.
And this village woman, woman,
woman of color, turns to them
and says no, no, you will
return to the battle.
And I will lead you.
She mounts a horse.
She dons a turban with
a sword in her hand,
with fire in her eyes,
she leads them back
into the flames when
no one else would.
She becomes the one
she is waiting for.
I tell that story
because I think
there is an impulse to desert.
There is an impulse to give
up, to keep our head down,
to play it safe.
But if we can call forth
the warriors within us
to take our hands
and lead us back
into the fire,
that's the only way
our generation will fight
the good fight here and now.
QUYEN DINH: And I think
I'm reflecting on,
I'm reflecting on
just how hard it
is for my parents to share
their experience surviving
the Vietnam War.
In this room, how many of
you, how many of your parents,
were the first ones
to come to the US?
And in this room, how
many of those parents
came because of fleeing
some sort of trauma,
political trauma, religious
trauma, economic trauma,
poverty?
We come from
communities-- and by we,
I want to talk from my own
experience being Vietnamese
American--
I come from a family
who has survived
bombings in their countries.
My parents got on a boat, sailed
across the South China Seas,
ended up in Malaysia.
And I was born in New Orleans.
And for my entire life, the
story of the Vietnam War
was rarely ever told.
And when my political
moment was actually
going to Washington
DC for the first time
as a high school senior, what
I was so stoked about seeing
was the Vietnam War Memorial.
Because this memorial
to me represented
why I was here in America.
And as I got there, I looked
at the Smiths and the Jones
and the Derricks and the Johns.
And I was looking for
the Dinhs, and the Trans,
and the Nguyens, and
the Ngos, and the Phams.
I was looking for all
the Vietnamese soldiers
who sacrificed their lives
in this fight for freedom.
And I started to get
really, really angry.
And I started to think about all
the children, all the people,
all the families, who died
in Vietnam who were really
pawns in wars, and why their
names weren't reflected
on this wall.
And I went back and talked
with my high school teacher
while everyone else was
at the museum gift shop.
And I just started bawling
and sharing with him
how confused I
felt, because I felt
so indebted to these
American soldiers who
had sacrificed their
lives and their families
for me to be here.
And yet, at the same
time, I felt so invisible.
And I felt betrayed.
And I didn't have
the words to express
what I was feeling at the time.
And I think going to
Berkeley and getting
my political
education I realized
this was the first time that I
felt marginalized in my country
where I felt like
this is not home.
And it was that
moment that led me
on my journey to really reclaim
what it is that who I am
and the history, the people,
the historical forces that
brought me here today.
And I think that's
the reason why
I am so passionate about
this work is because advocacy
is personal to me.
When I look at the
deportation orders,
I think about my cousin who
came as a teenager to the US
with a criminal
conviction record
because there was no support
at home, no support at schools.
And he has a deportation
order to Vietnam.
There are 15,000 other
Southeast Asian Americans
who have this same experience
and yet is not talked about.
When we talk about the
Affordable Care Act being taken
away, I think about my dad
who got ACA health insurance
coverage for the first time.
And I think about my cousins
who just came to the US
from Vietnam.
Who, because they
live in California,
are eligible to access
Affordable Care Act and health
care plans because we
expanded coverage for newly
arrived immigrant communities.
All of these policies
are so personal to me.
And I think when we each have
that moment of connection,
that's when you're able to see
a shift in how we understand
ourselves and how we understand
exercising our power by raising
our voices and by
being who we are.
VALARIE KAUR: I am so
moved by your moment
at the Vietnam Memorial.
And I want to share
with you, I think
what it tells us is the
importance of historical memory
and storytelling and
our charge for here now.
Because I had that
moment, my moment
was the 9/11 Memorial where
I have only gone for moments.
Because just as I mourn the
3,000 people who were killed,
I stand at the fountain.
I feel the spray of
the water at my face.
I run my hands over their names.
But in the museum and
at the memorial itself,
there is not a
moment of recognition
for all the violence that was
done in the aftermath of 9/11.
So it's like I
grieve my community.
I grieve my country.
And I want to be able to own
this narrative completely
but I felt invisible.
That changed this
last 9/11 anniversary.
I had a woman Carrie Kelly
who lost her stepfather
in the towers, he was
a fireman, invited
me to come and grieve with her.
And oh, I grieved.
There was something
in me that broke open.
And I was just sobbing,
because I realized for 15 years
I had not been given
permission to grieve on 9/11.
Because from that moment,
I had to work to protect
my community from being killed.
So she gave me permission to
enter that grief with her.
And then she did
something remarkable.
She said, let me come with you
to the memorial of Balbir Singh
Sodhi in Arizona.
And so she traveled with me.
And the 9/11 Memorial,
the whole world knows.
The memorial that lies at the
corner of a Chevron gas station
in Arizona nobody knows.
It's the spot where Balbir
Uncle bled to death.
And there's a tiny
plaque in the corner.
And I see this place as
the second ground zero.
It is the ground zero for
every single person who
was killed in reaction to
9/11, not just in hate crimes,
but in the wars abroad--
civilians and soldiers alike--
it is a second ground zero.
And I stood at that spot and
I put roses on the ground
next to his brother Rana Sodhi.
And Ranajeet turned to me--
this was just in
September, September 15.
And he said 15 years
and nothing has changed.
And I asked him,
Ranajeet, what is the one
thing we have not tried yet?
Who is the one person
we have not tried
to extend our love to yet?
And we said, it's the murderer.
It's the person
who took his life--
Frank Roque-- who is lingering
in a prison some miles away.
And so, out of
desperation almost,
we do something
that was unthinkable
before, we called the prison
the next morning to talk
to Balbir Sodhi's murderer.
And in the beginning, I think
it's a complete disaster.
Frank says, yes,
I'm sorry for what
happened on 9/11-- on 9/15.
But I'm also sorry for all
the people who died on 9/11.
And at this moment I think
there are limits to love.
How dare I think
that I could engage
in this moment of
reconciliation now?
And Rana Sodhi, he
hears what I can't.
He says, Frank, this
is the first time
I've ever heard you
say you were sorry.
He takes a step toward Frank.
Frank takes a step toward him.
He says, yes, I am sorry.
I'm sorry for what I did
to you and your family.
And when I go to heaven
to be judged by God,
I will ask to see your uncle.
And I will hug him and I
will ask for his forgiveness.
And Rana Sodhi says, we
have already forgiven you.
I tell that story
because the only reason
anyone knows it is because
we posted it online.
The time of Vietnam,
and even at the time
when September 11th
first happened,
we did not have the open
and free internet and all
the platforms we have to
tell our community stories.
Historical memory was owned by
the powerful few that framed
whose lives were grievable
and whose weren't.
And now we have tools.
We have tools to tell the
stories of those who you
are defending in deportations.
We have tools to tell Rana
Sodhi's story and his act
of revolutionary love.
We have tools now,
I can tell you
this is a second ground zero
to remember, to claim, as a way
to continue to fight
the good fight.
And so what you are doing here,
with the revolution that you
are all part of, and
giving communities voice
through Google and through all
the initiatives you support
is actually part of the
movement for social justice
in this country.
It means the world to us.
[APPLAUSE]
LORRIE MA: All right.
Let's get the round of applause.
So growing up, so I'm actually--
not many people know this--
but I grew up in China.
So I was born and
raised in China.
And I came here when I was 10.
And I was severely bullied in
school because I was different.
And one of the things
that growing up I was told
was if you just kept your
head down and just kept
doing what you were
doing, just stay silent,
you would just get through
this, and it's fine.
And this is something that
culturally was ingrained in me
to just be this sort of
silent model minority.
And my parents built their
success on the back of this,
just being silent, not
airing your "dirty laundry"
quote unquote, and
sort of staying
in this little confinement.
And a lot of people
actually, stereotypically,
feel that the success
of Asian American
is because they are
sort of this model
minority and this silent,
invisible population.
How do you reconcile
that with some
of the things that are happening
today and some of the activism
that you're sort
of advocating for?
PHIL YU: I mean for me,
look, the number one question
I get about my work, And
it's like why did you
call your blog Angry Asian Man?
Like what made you so angry?
Was there some inciting
moment like that?
And it really wasn't.
It really was just
coming on my own
this journey that I
was having towards
some sort of Asian American
political consciousness
through school, through
Asian American Studies.
So there wasn't any one-- like
I wasn't a victim of a hate
crime, and I was
like, oh, so mad I've
got to go to my computer
and start writing.
But if I look back-- so I
always tell people that--
but I look back and
it's called Angry Asian
Man because that is so--
that idea of angry Asian
anything is so in the face of,
it's so contrary to the
perception of Asians
in this country in the West.
It's like we're supposed to
be this the silent, the quiet
types.
The ones who don't raise our
voice, the ones who don't say
anything, and don't speak up.
And I was like I
just wanted something
that was confrontational,
that was provocative.
And so when people
visit the site,
they see that it's like it's
an affront to their senses,
angry Asian.
But when I look back
at my own journey,
I think there was
really one inciting--
there was an inciting moment.
The one that really sort
of lit a fire and made me
realize that I was a part of
a tradition that was already
existed of Asian
American activism,
of people who were speaking out.
It was when I learned about
the murder of Vincent Chin.
Do people here know
who Vincent Chin was?
Just a show of hands,
I want to just--
So for people who don't
know, Vincent Chin in 1982,
he was in Detroit, this
Chinese American guy.
He was out for his
bachelor party.
He was going to get married
in a couple of days.
He ends up getting in
an argument with a guy
at a strip club for
his bachelor party.
And the witnesses remember
overhearing the man saying
to Vincent, it's
because of you mother
fuckers that we're out of work.
And he was referring
to auto jobs being
lost to Japanese manufacturers.
They were in Detroit.
And the fight breaks out.
And Vincent Chin ends up
getting killed with a baseball
bat, his head bashed in.
Goes into a coma and
dies three days later.
Learning about this
case-- and so this case
it was about a hate
crime, but it was also
about the demand for
justice that swelled up
from a Pan Asian movement
fighting for justice
for Vincent Chin and
against his killers.
I learned about the case
nearly 20 years after the fact
when I was in college.
And I honestly when I learned
about it, for my first instinct
was to get really angry.
Not only because of what
happened and the circumstances
of the case.
That is infuriating.
But because like why haven't
I heard about this before?
Why am I only learning
about this now?
Like this is something
that is part of my history,
because it swelled up in me
just this idea of every moment
where someone called
me a racial slur,
where I was made to feel like
I did not belong in the country
that I was born in.
All that sort of just welled up.
And I realized it's like this
idea of finding your voice,
raising your voice, and
getting angry about something.
That was something I
had not been taught
by suppressing some of
these histories that
were relevant to me.
The history of civil
rights in this country
is amazing, and incredible,
and we owe a debt
to that as Asian American.
But so many people have taught
me that where's my place?
Like I'm absent
from that, you know?
At least that's what was
sort of taught in my way.
And I was like no, no, no.
There is a history of activism
amongst Asian Americans
in this country.
And so I realize that there is
this idea of us being quiet,
because it kind of
suppresses this identity
that we are allowed
to have, that we're
allowed to be part of
the things that shape
and mold this country.
And I'm talking about when
people holler and get mad
and get angry about
stuff, because that's
when shit gets done, you know?
VALARIE KAUR: So I'm the
director of the Revolutionary
Love Project.
And I love Angry Asian Man.
I love you.
And I also love the platform
and I love the name.
PHIL YU: Please call me Phil.
[LAUGHTER]
VALARIE KAUR: I think that
anger has such an important role
in our movements, a vital role.
And as Asian Americans, but also
as women, and as Asian women,
and South Asian women,
we are consistently
taught to bury our rage,
to suffocate our anger,
to compromise, to
sacrifice, for the good
of the family, or the wider
community, or the country.
When I define
revolutionary love, what
makes it revolutionary
is that we
are extending-- we're thinking
about love not as a passing
feeling, but as a commitment.
As a commitment
to extend our will
for the flourishing
of others, even
our opponents, and ourselves.
And when we love in the face
of fear, or rage, or vitriol,
then love can be revolutionary.
It can change things, right?
But love is not the
absence of rage.
Love, the first step
on the path of love
is actually owning
our moral outrage.
In the face of the
Executive Orders
coming down, in the face
of Vincent Chin's murder,
in the face Balbir
Singh Sodhi's murder,
in the face of Srinivasjeet's
murder, we ought to be angry.
And we need you to
be angry with us.
Because here's the thing.
If we hold our
rage in isolation--
Hannah Arendt says
isolation breeds tyranny.
But if we hold our
rage in isolation,
that's when it
festers into hate.
That's when it eats us alive.
And that's when cycles
of aggression continue.
But if we hold our
rage in community,
then we can release
its creative energy.
We walk together on
the path of love.
And eventually, eventually,
we may arrive in Forgiveness
because forgiveness
is not forgetting.
Like I will never forget what
happened to Balbir Uncle,
never.
Forgiveness is
freedom from hate.
That's what Rana Sodhi
taught me when he
forgave his brother's killer.
But he was free
enough from hate.
So this Administration
that we're
fighting, that so many
of us are fighting,
I refuse to hate them, because
I refuse to be like them.
I will fight them
with my moral outrage
and with love as
my guiding ethic.
And eventually, maybe,
it will arrive us
to a place of forgiveness.
Because in the end,
our enemies are not
these individual bad guys.
It's not Vincent's murderer.
It's not Frank Roque.
It's not even this
president or any terrorist
who tries to attack us.
Our enemy are the cultures
and the institutions of power
that allow them to hurt us.
We can take out as many bad
guys as we want and more
will step into their place.
But a real, lasting
social change
is changing the context,
changing culture,
changing institutions of power.
And so revolutionary love,
the call to revolutionary love
that we're building right
now in our movement,
is really taking from
Gandhi and King and Mandela
and offering a way to
sustain our movement.
And that's not just in the
next few weeks or months,
but in the years to come.
And I think if we walk
with a moral outrage,
but we're walking on the path
of love, then we'll get there.
QUYEN DINH: And I think
walking on the path of healing.
And I think about healing
because we have all
received those messages,
or as Asian American women.
I've certainly been told from
my parents to not talk so loud.
And I have to recognize that
this is how they survived.
That for them, as
refugees to America
without a single
word of English,
this is how they survived.
And that recognition allows me
to understand that maybe this
isn't who they want me to be.
I am someone else.
In fact, they raised me to be
a very different, strong, loud
person.
And by recognizing that, I
release my anger towards them.
I release my anger towards them
and choose to own my voice.
I think that on an
individual level,
it also happened-- this
is on an individual level,
but it also happens
on a systems level
in the communities and the
cultures that we create.
And oftentimes, I
think about reclaiming
what silence means actually.
So one of the concepts
that we learn a lot about,
or that we hear a lot about now
these days, is implicit bias.
Particularly, against
African-American communities
being really with huge
assumptions that these are
communities who are violent.
And young African-American
boys and girls
get pushed out of school and
get disciplined at higher rates.
Whereas Asian
Americans, maybe we
have benefited from this
because of the assumption
from educators that you're
the superstar students.
And oftentimes, I share silence
does not mean understanding.
Silence can mean that they
are crying out for help
and they don't know what
to do to get that help.
And as institutional
leaders, I think
it is our responsibility
to test those assumptions
and check our assumptions
and create spaces
where our voices can be
heard, where our voices lead
to decisions that
are made beyond just
our own individual selves,
and the work that we
do 9:00 to 5:00.
LORRIE MA: And I
think I want to pivot
that since you kind
of mentioned that you
are an executive director.
How do we do that
in the workplace?
How do we have those
racial conversations?
How do we break the silence
or own the silence or whatever
it is that we're supposed to
be doing in the workplace?
How do we kind of propel
this conversation forward?
QUYEN DINH: I'm sure
Valarie and Phil have
amazing insights on this, too.
But some of the questions
that you prepared for us
were about the Bamboo
Ceiling, and what
it means to be an Asian
American woman in particular,
and I was sharing
with Phil and Valarie
that I have no idea
what that means.
Because I spent my entire
career in a nonprofit sector
that was led by
Asian American women.
And now I'm the fourth executive
director of our National
Advocacy organization.
And in our team of 12, we
have 10 amazing, fierce women.
And one of the
tremendous moments
that we're in
right now, I think,
is to challenge ourselves
to love even more.
When our President
got elected, I
encouraged my team to
actually come into the office
and to come into work.
And we spent two hours
in really deep mourning
and in deep conversation
with each other.
And we recognized that this
space had to be created,
not only to share how
attacked we felt, how isolated
we felt by this decision that
America does not accept who we
are, but also a
place to allow us
to talk about our fathers, our
cousins, who voted for Donald
Trump.
All of his supporters
who are going
to be betrayed by
so many policies
are going to really hurt them.
And what that means for us
to reach across communities
to really build
this surge of love,
of unity, and of understanding
with one another.
And that's how we created
that space at SEARAC
is really being very intentional
about creating that time for us
to be together and
to continue creating
those spaces for
those conversations
to happen and recognize
that sometimes it starts
with silence and just being
able to be OK with that,
but being able to move into
really deep conversation
and dialogue with deep trust
and respect to one another.
PHIL YU: In talking
about the Bamboo Ceiling,
I have very little
insight, honestly,
in terms of traditional
work spaces.
I can say this, it starts
with things like this,
having conversations like this.
But it also starts with
acknowledging being Asian,
being Asian American.
It doesn't mean nothing.
It doesn't mean a neutral
identity in the workspace.
It's doesn't mean like nearly
white or it doesn't mean like--
the fact that there is
an employee affinity
group here for Asians, like
make that mean something.
Don't just mean like,
hey, we all kind
of look like each other, so.
What does that mean?
Oh, we all like
certain kinds of food?
There is a challenge that
comes with that you know.
And I speak to a
lot of colleges,
a lot of student groups, a
lot of Asian American student
groups.
And I challenge them make
your Asian American--
it's like the Asian
American student
association on their campus.
And there's a fairly
large, robust membership.
But like make that gathering
about something other
than Boga nights at your campus.
What do you want this being
Asian American to be about?
What kind of resource
do you want to be?
What kind of space
do you want to create
that this Asian
American identity exists
beyond just like the check box?
But what happens when
you come face-to-face
with some kind of
discrimination on campus
and they need someone
to talk about this,
they need a space
to talk about this?
Are you going to
be in that space?
Because you're
the clear, obvious
mobilized group to do so.
Or is it just going to
be about Boga nights?
Is it just going to
be about the fashion
talents-- the Asian
fashion talent, which
is awesome and fun.
And we need to have
those spaces, too.
But like what's it
going to be about?
So I think it really
is about being
intentional about the
gathering, about the group,
about the community
that you create
when under this banner of
Asian American, you know.
VALARIE KAUR: Sonia
is coming to my mind.
Sonia is a pharmacist
in Chicago,
an Indian American mother.
And I was with her last week.
And she came to me after
work completely distressed
saying that she was at the cash
register when a man walked,
a customer walked,
into the store
and started to say
all of my problems
are because of you foreigners
and ranted on and on,
basically echoing
what he has heard
from the President
and people in power
but directing it at Sonia.
And she stays quiet
working the register.
Her white coworkers
are next to her.
The man leaves.
And after the man leaves the
white coworkers turn to her
and say are you OK?
She's shaken.
She says yes, I'm OK.
And she says to me,
what should I have done?
I feel so ashamed.
I should have done more.
And I said no, actually
it's not on you to do more.
It was on your
coworkers in that moment
in their relative
positions of power
to stand up and
defend you, to create
the culture in the workplace
that they want to create.
And I told her the story
has been keeping me alive.
The story of a Punjabi language
professor here in San Jose.
After 9/11, all
those years ago, he
was sitting on a bus in
San Jose on his way home
from the university.
He was looking out
the window when
a man at the front of the bus
stood up, turned around, red
in the face, and began
pointing at him and saying,
hey, you f-ing terrorists,
go back to your country.
Get off this bus.
Go back to where you come from.
And my professor wears
a turban and beard,
looks like my grandfather,
looks out the windows
and is just praying
for the moment to pass.
Right?
What else can he do but
pray for the moment to pass.
Something remarkable happens.
The other people on the
bus began to stand up--
white, black, Latino,
Asian, they stand up.
And they take this man's arm.
And they say sit down, sit down.
And the man sits down.
The bus comes to a stop and my
professor gets off this bus.
And the man gets off this bus.
And the man walks
up to my professor,
and puts out his arm.
And at this point, I'm waiting
for the violence to happen.
But the man takes my professor's
hand and shakes it, and says,
I just lost my granddaughter
in that second plane that
went into that second tower.
I am angry.
I am sorry.
What stays with
me from that story
is that we are the
people on that bus.
We are the people who in the
most ordinary circumstances,
in a Google roundtable, in a
conference room here on campus,
on a bus ride home, in the
streets, in the school yards,
at our kitchen tables, we
can stand up and do the most
courageous things to
defend and protect
people who are in harm's way,
to create the kind of workplace
culture, but also the
culture in our country
that we are longing for.
Each of you has
that warrior in you.
Each of you has the ability
to stand, to stand up.
And we will only do this
if we do it together.
Because here's the truth.
This is a dark moment
in our country.
I've been fighting for 15 years.
I don't know how I'm going to
this explain this to my son.
I'm touring preschools.
And I can't even send him to
preschool right now because I
know the data on
bullying for a little boy
with long hair who keeps his
hair as part of his faith.
This a dark moment
for me personally.
It's a dark moment
for our country.
And so if this is dark for you,
know that you are not alone.
And this is the one thing I
leave with you, the one thing
that I have held onto
as a mother is this.
What if-- what if
this darkness is not
the darkness of the tomb?
What if this darkness is
the darkness of the womb?
What if our America is
not dead, but a country
still waiting to be born?
Right?
Langston Hughes says let America
be America again, the land that
has never been.
It has never been that for me.
It has never been that for
black folks in this country,
for indigenous folks.
The land that has never
been and yet still must be.
So I swear this oath let
America be America again.
Let us make it so.
Because what if this moment is
our nation's great transition?
What does the
midwife ask us to do?
She says to breathe.
And she says to push.
Because if we don't
push, we will die.
Like if we don't push, our
nation, our America will die.
We don't go into battle
alone, there's warriors,
and we don't give birth alone.
So I say hold fast
to one another.
Hold fast to your coworkers,
your family, your friends.
Hold fast to one another
as brothers and sisters
in the fight.
Help one another stand
up when you need to.
Help one another
breathe and push.
And then breathe and then push.
And then keep breathing
and then keep pushing.
[APPLAUSE]
LORRIE MA: All right.
So I know that we have a ton
of questions that are brewing.
So for those of you who are
here, if you have any questions
and are live, we'll
take live questions.
Feel free to line up at the mic.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Thanks to the three
of you for coming today.
Thanks to AGN for organizing.
My heart's still kind of
racing from all the stories.
I've had the opportunity
to lead with others
an online community,
anonymous user names all
that for Asian Americans.
And we wanted it to
be like a safe space
where people talk about things
that they don't normally
get to talk about.
And it worked up to an extent.
But what we found over
time is that there
is a lot of infighting.
Like there was like the
gender between genders,
so-and-so stood
up for Asian men,
but she's married
to a white man,
so she can't speak
for Asian men.
Or so-and-so is mixed race,
we don't consider them
as part of the community.
East Asians versus South Asians.
How can we get past all that
and focus on a higher level
and stand together as
a community online,
in person, just in general?
PHIL YU: As someone who spends a
great deal, quite a bit of time
online, and also receives
quite a bit of criticism
online from anonymous
folks, I can only
say that like in terms
of the infighting of like
who gets to say what--
like all that stuff gets
in the way of actually
accomplishing anything, right?
It's like criticizing the voice
that it comes from where you're
saying like this
person gets to be Asian
and this person does not is like
what good does that do anybody?
Honestly.
I am really an
opponent of people
who are policing Asian
American identities.
Asian American identities
are like whoever
identifies as Asian American,
that's who you are, man.
I'm sick of people saying
like this person is Asian.
This person is biracial so
they are not fully Asian.
That's complete bullshit.
This community has
enough problems as it is.
And we're going to
start dividing up
like who gets to say what?
Whose voice is more valid?
So that's kind of what I have
to say about that in terms
of policing these voices.
But the other side
of that is like we
have to find common
ground about the things
like deciding who gets to fight
on our behalf, that actually
doesn't get to the
actual fighting part.
I mean that's just
still fighting about who
gets to be our spokesman.
It's like you know what?
I don't want spokesmen.
I want people to just be
the ones who do the work
and be the ones engaged
in the fight, you know?
And you're talking
about online spaces.
Like I work in the online
space, but I am the first one
to acknowledge that
only gets you so far.
Like the work that I do, it
only starts a conversation.
I'm not actually--
I'll be the first one to
say the real work gets
done when people get together
and start talking offline.
Online is super
powerful and important.
The message boards, and
stuff like that, Twitter,
powerful, powerful tools.
And I love the work
that I do as a blogger
from behind my laptop.
But it's really when we
come to spaces like this
and we're having conversations
face-to-face where
things actually get done.
That's when the pot
really gets stirred.
So I'm sorry about
the online people,
like the trolls, and
everything like that.
But it's not just
trolls, just people
having different opinions.
I think that we ought to
look at what we're actually
fighting about.
The stuff we're bickering about
actually is not productive.
LORRIE MA: OK.
We'll take another
live question.
Then we'll go to the DORY.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a first
generation immigrant
in the US for 15 years.
And I'm your typical Asian guy
who doesn't look into politics,
and stick my head down,
no bubble in California
in Bay Area in Google.
I guess I have a son now in San
Jose that's five months old.
I feel he's going to feel
like one of you guys.
Like he's going to grow up and
feel like he's really American
and all these
injustices to Asians
are happening in this country.
Right?
I'm like what's going on?
Like why are you
guys so worried?
So I'm honest.
Like I read the columnist.
I read "New York Times,"
about the major US
racial issues are on the
Muslims right now, right?
I really want to know
number one if you can
answer this question directly.
Because like all the guys
have resonated with the talk.
But for me, half the talk,
I did not resonate on.
Like all these men in his
history and stuff like that.
It happened.
I don't have a parent that's
suffered through this.
I don't have a Japanese parent
who went to intern camp.
I don't have a
Vietnamese parent, right?
And China and US actually
were close in history?
So I'm Taiwanese, too,
my parents are Taiwanese.
So my question is
number one directly like
will there be issues
today that I as an Asian--
I was born in the
US, that's the irony.
But I'm raised in Asia.
So what is a
current topic that I
need to be paying attention to?
Number two, what is a
good media source for me
to educate myself?
And number three what can I
do to understand my son better
when he grows up?
So three questions, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
LORRIE MA: It's a lot.
VALARIE KAUR: It is a lot.
QUYEN DINH: I feel
like we all want
to share something, so thank
you for being really honest.
I think that actually one of
the reasons why our community is
so complex is because
we are comprised
of multiple generations of
Asians to this country, right?
I think the biggest issue--
there are so many, but
I would say immigration.
We are all here because
of immigration policy.
And we have been benefited
because of the 1965 Immigration
Nationality Act.
This is a huge transition from
the Chinese Exclusion Act.
And now, our country
is shifting in being
the most closed off it has ever
been historically as a country.
And as a community that has so
benefited from these policies,
I really believe it's
our responsibility
to protect that legacy.
So if it's one issue, I'm
going to say immigration.
News sources?
I think you just have
to be really smart
and be a really good
critical thinker.
Which is why I really
think critical thinking
skills are important to
teach at the K-12 level.
But folks might
have other insights.
And in terms of
your son, I think
having conversations
with him that maybe you
weren't allowed to have,
and just listening to him,
and recognizing that
you are a part of him.
And he will continue
your legacy.
He'll be probably different
from all of us actually.
But that you have given
him this opportunity
to define a new identity,
a new self for himself
and so support that.
PHIL YU: My daughter is seven
months old, my first child.
And my question is
same as yours about
like how will she grow up.
And I hope that she'd be a
woke ass Asian American woman,
you know.
To touch upon something
you said in terms
of like I don't relate
to this-- and like look.
I'm Korean American.
I've gone through relatively
little personal struggle
in my life.
But when I said I became
Asian American, that
means my struggle
became her struggle,
my struggle became her struggle.
You know adopting
that mentality really
is what drives me and
drives the work that I do.
And so I know a lot of people
will fall back on that thing,
I can't relate.
And that's not really--
I mean, I feel sorry for
you, but I don't relate.
But at some point-- and I'm
going to paraphrase something
that someone told me.
At some point you got to ask
yourself are you interested
in justice or just us?
And you have to define
what just us is.
So when I adopted Asian
American as my identity,
that's what I took
on, that us part.
VALARIE KAUR: Yeah.
Our destinies are intertwined.
And therefore I can't
give you a single issue.
Leading with love
means acknowledging
that everyone's struggle is
intertwined with our own.
That I cannot live
if you are dying.
I cannot stand by if
you are suffering.
What does that mean right now?
What does it mean
to respond with love
when so many communities
are in harm's way?
I mean just even looking
at the first Executive
Orders the first week
of this Administration,
we had an Executive
Order that build
a wall along our southern
border, that punished sanctuary
cities for offering refuge to
undocumented immigrants, that
started the construction
of pipelines
on indigenous sacred lands,
that repealed sections
of the Affordable Care Act,
that now have enacted now
the second version of the
Muslim ban that affects not just
immigrants and refugees
but Muslims and Sikhs
and others in this country.
And now we have promises
of voting rights
and criminal justice
and mass incarceration.
But everything will be
affected by this Administration
and these policies.
And so, to stand next to my
Latino brothers and sisters,
and my indigenous brothers and
sisters, and my black brothers
and sisters, and my Muslim
brothers and sisters,
and my Asian American brothers--
I know that sounds exhausting.
I know what does it look like
each day if all of our issues
are interconnected and we are
in an intersectional moment?
And that the only way to fight
for a movement of justice
now is to know that
we fight together.
I think that means
deciding how you show up
in your daily and weekly life.
So what I'm telling
you is that what
it means to be an engaged
citizen in America today
is to call Congress once a day.
Yes, once a day.
Like I have the number on
speed dial on my phone.
I call once a day.
And I look at the news.
It's the New York Times," the
same thing you're reading.
And whatever community
is in harm's way--
I mean there are so many--
but right now I choose one.
And I call my senator
or a representative
and I tell them I stand in
solidarity with that community,
stand up, be emboldened
to stand up with me.
Once a day.
It means once a week or
once every two weeks,
showing up to the march,
showing up to the vigil,
showing up in community not
just online, but in person.
That's what
solidarity looks like.
That's what love looks like.
And if you start to take
your son to these places,
you don't have to do
very much, because he'll
be hearing the stories and
having the conversations
that you didn't get to have.
And you'll be learning from him.
Because in order
to love someone,
you all need to answer
three questions--
who are you?
What is at stake for you?
What is my role in
your flourishing?
What is your role in mine?
Number one is who are you?
Every day I look
into my son's eyes.
Phil's daughter is
seven months old.
My son is two years old.
He is changing every day.
Every day I have to
ask him who are you?
What is at stake for you?
What is my role in
your flourishing
and what is your role in mine?
He didn't want me
to get on a plane
to come over here today and
spend a day away from him.
But he has a role
in my flourishing
which is to allow his
mommy to be her best self.
So we are tied together.
Not just our communities,
but our families,
and our collective flourishing.
So if you do that, if you
take your son to these places,
if you ask him these
questions, if you
start to create the
culture that you
want for the country
in your own home,
then you're part
of the good fight?
AUDIENCE: Great answers.
Thank you.
LORRIE MA: We'll take a
question from the DORY.
So it says what
work if any have you
seen in regards to
diversity inclusion
for Southeast Asian groups?
Because quote "Asian"
is used so broadly,
often there is little attention
given to the increased
representation for more
under-represented groups whose
experiences can
be very different.
QUYEN DINH: And is this
in particular to Google?
LORRIE MA: Feel free
to speak to who.
QUYEN DINH: Let's start with
Google, since we're here.
We're having this really
courageous conversation
about race, right?
I think the first
step is actually
recognizing that
there's a problem
and really owning
that inequity exists
within the Asian
American community,
especially around
socioeconomic outcomes.
And by starting with Google,
one really simple thing
could be trying to collect this
aggregated data on the Google
community.
So of the-- how many Asian
American Google folks
are there?
Googlers are there?
LORRIE MA: I don't know
if we have those numbers.
PHIL YU: Hello bunch.
[LAUGHTER]
QUYEN DINH: Of the hella
bunch Asian American folks,
or folks who identify as
Asian, how many are Vietnamese?
How many are Hmong?
How many are Cambodian?
How many are Lao?
How many are Taiwanese?
How many are Thai?
How many are Malaysian?
And I share that because the
Asian American community is not
the same.
We're not a monolith.
And when I try to recruit
for positions at SEARAC
where we're trying
to pass legislation.
We're building grassroots
movements and community
building across the
country, I struggle
to find folks with a
master's degree or a master's
in public policy or a
master's in social work
who are a Southeast Asian.
Because the reality
is that two in three
Southeast Asian Americans
don't have a college degree.
And so you see that manifested
on the professional level
in different industries where
communities are actually
represented.
And I think starting there with
really recognizing that there
is a problem is the first step.
LORRIE MA: Let's take
another live question.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you everyone
for coming today.
So I have a question more
about personal identity.
I was born in the US,
but I grew up in Taiwan,
but I'm at a
bilingual school that
taught both American
and Chinese history.
And I had most of my career
in the United States.
So I don't really
know what I am.
I don't feel like I
belong in America.
I don't feel like I belong when
I go back to Taiwan or in Asia.
And so I've always called
myself Asian American.
But I don't really feel like
I'm the same as everyone
else in this room either.
So I'm just curious from
your personal experience,
you know, where do you
fit in and how do you
find that belonging?
VALARIE KAUR: I just want
to say, I know you're heart.
So growing up as
a third generation
Sikh American in the farmlands
of central California--
what does that look like?
It means that when I would go
to the gurdwara, the Sikh house
of worship, there were
mostly immigrant families.
And I felt like an outsider
to my own Sikh community
because my father was
born and raised here.
He went to college
and was part of a frat
and he named me Valarie
after Valentine's Day,
not after like anything
I tried to pretend--
No.
But it's after an
American holiday,
it's not in Sikh scripture.
So I--
[LAUGHTER]
So I felt like an outsider
to my own community.
And then at school, of
course, predominantly white,
very conservative,
very Christian,
I was constantly
called these names,
but also told that I would
go to hell because I was not
Christian.
And so I spent my
entire childhood
feeling like I was in between,
like I am not fully Sikh
according to them.
I'm not fully American
And this in-between
space I felt like I just
wanted to collapse it.
I thought about changing my
name to go this direction.
And I thought about
doing something else
to go in this direction.
And finally, it was only
after, really after 9/11,
and understanding
what I was seeing
that I recognized this
in-between space that I
occupied.
This in-between space
that you're standing in
is actually a space of
tremendous strength.
You can see things that
other people can't see.
You can see things about America
and Taiwan and China that
others of us in this
room cannot see.
I can see things that
others cannot see.
And that means I can tell
stories from this space that
others cannot tell.
I can exercise my
voice from this space.
My best friend tells me speak
even if your voice trembles.
So even if your voice
is trembling, speak.
Because your particular
truth is something
that this country, this
community here on this campus,
needs.
We need you.
So own where you are.
And also know that
you're not alone
in where you are,
that so many of us
are occupying these
in-between spaces.
A whole generation
of millennials
are in these in-between spaces.
And one of the fallacies of
races to put us in these cages,
right?
We can break open those cages.
We can show that America is not
a melting pot, it's a mosaic.
And it's made up of
all different kinds
of pieces and histories
and stories and truths.
And your job is to
let your truth shine.
Your job is to let
your truth sing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PHIL YU: I just
want to add to that.
There is no corner of
Asian America where
this diverse, incredible, wide
spanning Asian America, where
somebody's going to go and
feel like I completely belong,
like I totally belong here.
There's a corner
everywhere where
someone is going to like I
don't feel like I belong.
And that's kind of
what's awesome about it.
But I think everyone has
felt like an outsider
in some space of the space
where they're supposed
to feel like they belong.
I think we can all
relate on some level.
And then ditto
what Valarie said.
[LAUGHTER]
LORRIE MA: Great.
Next.
AUDIENCE: If you ask most
Americans about the Holocaust,
everybody knows what it is.
But if you talk
about Vincent Chin,
I saw about maybe
20% of the people
here in this room
raising their hand when
I talk to people who
are not from California,
they don't even know about
the Japanese internment.
What are some of the larger
effort going across the country
to educate the world at
large, and America at large,
about the injustice
against Asian Americans
and the world in general?
PHIL YU: I don't know
specifically to much
about education
issues, but I can only
say from what I
know from people who
are on the ground doing
some work is that it happens
on a local level.
I mean a lot of it
is super motivated
by people within schools,
within school districts,
to educate about--
in California, we have
Fred Korematsu Day.
That's not a nationwide holiday.
But it's celebrating
a civil rights
leader who stood up
to the incarceration
of Japanese Americans.
I have a friend of
mine, this couple,
they have two kids 10 and 11
years old at their school.
Their school was
celebrating Dr. Seuss week
in conjunction with National
Book something week, reading
week, or something right?
And they're
celebrating Dr. Seuss.
People love Dr. Seuss.
But a lot of people don't
know that Dr. Seuss actually
has a history of making really
racist cartoons during World
War II against
Japanese Americans,
painting them as the enemy
in super racist caricature.
So my friends, their
kids, 10, and 11,
took it upon themselves--
these are some woke ass
kids-- they took it upon
themselves to create flyers.
They designed themselves,
they printed up.
And they passed it out
at school to their class
and would say did you know
that Dr. Seuss is racist?
Did you know that he made
these racist cartoons?
They got it confiscated by the
teachers and a note home saying
dear, Mr Wong, while
we appreciate your kids
taking the initiative
to be socially aware,
these not allowed.
But I was like, that is amazing.
But it took these kids to
provide an alternate point
of view than just
go along with sort
of the celebration of this
figure, who most people love
the work that they know about.
But I think stuff
like that, that's
just a really cute
example of something
that-- but I feel like it takes
efforts like that where people
start a different
conversation entirely
where you have to create this
alternate thing than what's
been ingrained.
Like I said, I got
super mad about learning
about Vincent Chin in Ethics
Studies course in college.
It took getting to college
and definitely not everybody
gets to take Ethnic
Studies courses.
And so personally,
if it were up to me,
I would push for ethnic
studies at the high school,
junior high level, honestly.
VALARIE KAUR: So my most
recent social justice issue
was net neutrality.
And there were fellow
advocates who'd
been with me for
many years working
on hate crimes,
mass incarceration,
solitary confinement,
immigration, thinking
what are you doing taking on
the issue of internet freedom
as a social justice issue?
I was working here
at Stanford Law.
And I want to say I felt
so proud of the stand
Google took on this issue.
Because I chose net neutrality
as a social justice issue
because my life as
an activist would not
be possible without it.
PHIL YU: No.
VALARIE KAUR: I had no way
to tell, to show my film,
if it weren't for the
open and free internet.
Activists like us, you
wouldn't have a blog,
we wouldn't have
our calls to action.
There's a whole generation
of activists now
who are telling the stories of
Vincent Chin and Balbir Singh
Sodhi and Srinivas
Kuchibhotla, because
of the open and free internet.
And so there are
resources available to you
now in ways that
they weren't before.
And the first film that
we made, "Divided We
Fall" about hate
crimes after 9/11
also includes history
honoring the Japanese American
internment.
And so that film has
been used in classrooms
all around the country.
We've made it
available for free.
So many resources out
there for you online.
But if you go to
revolutionarylove.net
you can find this film and
a whole lot of other calls
to action to help you tell the
stories that need to be told.
LORRIE MA: We have this
question from the DORY.
Asian American are the largest
minority group at Google.
How can we get this group
more involved in the issues
surrounding more
underrepresented minorities
at Google?
On the other side of the
coin, what are the issues
that Asian American
Googlers needs support
from from other
underrepresented groups?
QUYEN DINH: So this is an--
go ahead.
PHIL YU: No.
Ah.
[LAUGHTER]
On the question of how do we get
other Asian American involved?
Like that's the question that
is asked of me by every student
group on every--
Asian American student
group on every campus.
How do I get the Asian
American on this campus
to give a shit about what
we give a shit about?
It's like the problem is that
you can't get someone else,
you can't care on their behalf,
like you've got to get them--
they have to come around
to being the ones who move.
So you can do all that
mobilizing you want,
at some point it has
to be the initiative
from within the individual.
There's no secret
link that's going
to trick somebody into caring.
So I don't know.
I don't know what
it takes in terms of
like how do I get
people to care?
Like they have to care.
I don't know what magic
key there is to it.
OK.
Yeah.
VALARIE KAUR: Well
I was just thinking
about how you are
like you have to opt
into Asian American
identity, right?
And if your definition
of Asian American
includes me, that means
when I'm at the vigil
and I'm burying my people,
cremating my people,
you're going to be right
there with me, right?
Because you see me as
part of who you are.
And the way to do that, the way
to see one another as brothers
and sisters so that we
care is through stories.
That is the only magic
key I found in my 15 years
as an activist.
It was never the lawsuit or
the Op Ed or the sound bite.
It was always
telling a story that
made people see what it
is like through our eyes,
feel what we feel.
I saw so many of you wipe
away tears when some of us
were telling these stories.
If you feel what we feel that
stories can cultivate empathy,
and stories can cultivate
that kind of empathy
required to inspire
action, collective action.
I don't think we get Asian
Americans to stand up out
of a sense of duty
or obligation.
Love is not an
exchange economy, I'll
do it for you so
that you'll do it.
No, it's like the
call to love is
to ask one another who are you?
And the best way to
ask one another who are
is to hear each other's stories,
to be moved by one another,
and then show up for one
another when we need each other.
So the fact that we're
having forums like this where
a lot of this is testimony
asking you to be with us
and hearing you so that we
can be with you through films,
through roundtables, online,
on the ground, in person.
The more that the
companies like Google
invest in that
kind of work, then
we won't be pulling teeth
to get people to show up,
we'll just be showing up.
QUYEN DINH: Yeah.
I was going to say, this
is a Google question.
This is a Google conversation.
I can't pretend to know
what happens on this campus.
I am in a totally different
world, where I'm like,
OK, I don't know why my
Google Drive file was
like duplicating,
but like that's
like the extent my relationship.
You all-- and the way that
I think about advocacy
is really about
owning your story
and really starting there,
And having not this discussion
with us as panelists, but
having a discussion with you
all as a community to understand
who you are, what you care
about, what are the challenges
that you experience,
and also what are the challenges
that other people of color
experience at Google.
Where is their common
passion and love?
And it's not going to happen
with one conversation or two
or three.
But it will.
It will happen if there
is that commitment
to really understanding
who we are as a community.
LORRIE MA: Great We have
two more live questions.
AUDIENCE: I think I'm
going to break this.
I have so many
things on my mind,
I'll try to pose my question
as clearly as I can.
So during the
election, I happened
to meet a couple of
people like Uber drivers
and they were Trump supporters.
And I asked them why had
they voted for Trump.
The answer was very common.
And there was one thing that was
very common and similar to what
Phil had mentioned that
immigrants had taken jobs
from them.
My personal opinion, I pay
shitloads of taxes every year,
but I just didn't have
the facts to explain
to them that this is not true.
And this was a question for me
as well, is this actually true?
If she's a mother of two
and she doesn't have money
to feed her kids.
And somebody who
has the authority
is feeding to her that
all immigrants have
taken over the job and that's
why you don't have money.
I wonder these kind
of forums are good,
but is there any
platform for people
who actually think that
that is the reason that they
don't have jobs
because immigrants
have taken over the jobs?
Have you ever spoken to anybody?
I tried to look online, but
I couldn't find any fact
where they could
explain that whatever
tax money that
immigrants would pay
would also go towards
the economy of America
and not their own country.
And I wondered if you have
anything online or any forums
or any discussions to
people who actually think
that that's the reason
why they are out of jobs
or why there are
against immigrants?
QUYEN DINH: Data
can be manipulated.
So there's data from very
conservative think tanks saying
that immigrants are
taking our jobs.
There's also very
substantial data
that says that is not the case.
And I would take a
step back actually
in thinking about this
Uber conversation.
I would ask why
do you think that?
Is this something that
you have experienced?
Or is it something that
you've heard on the news?
Because very often
times, I think
it's hearing things on the news
through outlets that manipulate
information and frame what is at
crisis in a very different way.
Because I think
what is at crisis
is that low income
communities need more jobs
and that we as a
country have not
been able to grow enough
infrastructure here
for all Americans of all
socioeconomic ladders
to have access to those jobs.
So those coal miners
in Pennsylvania,
is Donald Trump bringing
back the coal industry?
I don't know how he's
going to do that.
But that conversation is not
one, that honest conversation,
is not one that's being had.
And my interpretation
is, therefore,
that they're manipulating
fears of Americans who
want to make a living, who
want to make an honest earning,
and be able to keep
their families together.
And they are manipulating
that sense of fear
and that sense of
scarcity instead
of focusing on the
real question at hand,
which is how are we going
to create new jobs for all
of America?
How are you going to do that?
Show me through your policies,
not through your rhetoric,
show me through your
policies how you're
going to create this America?
PHIL YU: You're also
operating under the assumption
that a conversation like
that in the Uber car
or whatever that
the person is going
to be persuaded or dissuaded
by facts, by actual facts, when
I know that a lot of the
times we're in that situation,
it's like the person has
already made up their mind.
They're not interested in
being persuaded with numbers.
That's where you have to have
a more personal conversation
than just I'm more
right than you.
There's something more
to it than that you know.
LORRIE MA: Great.
Yeah.
We have time for
one last question.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of people who
have made up their mind
already about a lot of things,
my parents immigrated here from
the Philippines 35 years ago.
They are your prototypical
survivors here in the US.
Made their way here.
Raised me and my two
brothers to also be survivors
and to excel and to kind of
make our way without kind
of ruffling too many feathers.
And it was only
after I came out here
to California going
to college out here
that I kind of
had my mind opened
and to be exposed to what
being Asian American meant,
and just kind of being accepting
of other cultures as well.
But where I struggle is kind
of in having that conversation
back with my parents,
with the older
generation, the survivors.
They have they seem to
have a little bit more
of a mental block about these
issues because of the situation
that they went through
many years ago.
So do you have any
advice for kind
of how to approach conversations
with the older generations?
Because I think our age group
are more socially accepting.
We are talking
about these issues,
whereas my parents and
that generation are not.
PHIL YU: For me, that's
another argument--
it's not an argument, but
another conversation that's not
going to be--
no one's going to be
persuaded by being
like I'm more right than
you, especially when you're
dealing with your own parents.
That needs to be
approached with love.
And I think a lot of that
comes from sort of exhibiting
and showing the way you live,
the relationship you have,
the relationships that
you have and the things
that you stand for.
And then not just
like those crazy kids,
but it's like this is I'm very
passionate about these things.
I'm passionate about-- I
don't know what particularly
what kind of attitudes
you're speaking to,
but it does take sometimes
even the stodgiest, most
like ingrained kind
of thinking can
be persuaded by
people who live out
and model a certain way of life,
even from those crazy kids.
So I do think it
is something that
needs to be approached
from showing an experience
rather than being like
you're wrong mom or dad.
You're out of your mind.
That's me talking as a kid
and having those conversations
where you're going to
run into some blocks.
But I also think that it's OK
to take a breather from that
and be like not so
frustrated, because I
know a lot people who
are like my parents
are driving me crazy.
But it's also OK
to keep on trying
it's a long game sometimes.
QUYEN DINH: I was just going
to say that my dad still
doesn't know what I do really.
[LAUGHTER]
If I were to tell him
I'm an engineer, ah yeah,
it's awesome.
Executive director, hmm.
Policy?
Hmm, weird.
He is the apolitical
Republican actually,
Republican by history
and experience
as opposed to policy.
And in my--
I don't know-- like 15
years ish of work now,
it's been really
moving to just have
conversations with
him about why he
thinks the way that he thinks.
And moments of random
education kind of open up,
and that's when I share with him
a little bit about the policy
work that we do.
And I do try to
make it personal.
So when we talk about
deportation, for example,
it's not an issue that folks
think that Asian American are
impacted by.
And for the Southeast
Asian American experience,
it's even less known.
And I shared with him, you know
when you think of my cousin--
who my dad sponsored over
as like a 14-year-old--
I said, do you remember
what his experience
was like growing up without
parents really here in the US?
He said, yeah.
I felt really guilty
about it because I
wish I had been able
to give him more.
And I said you did
everything you could.
But why weren't the
schools helping?
Why weren't there any
resources or support
there to prevent
him from getting
into gangs in the first place?
And I said that's
the reason why we
do the work we do is to try
to fight for people like
[INAUDIBLE] to say that no,
he needed support policies
and programs that were there.
And it was a light
switch moment for my dad.
And so I see this as
an ongoing conversation
and as an ongoing journey
for us to continue
to get to know one another.
And I look forward
to my conversations
with him about the
Trump Administration
and see what happens,
because I really
do want to know what is on his
heart, and what is on his mind,
and how he
understands the world,
and how we can change our
understanding of the world
together.
LORRIE MA: All right.
With that, I would like a round
of applause for our panelists.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'll have Frances come up.
FRANCES: We have soup.
Before you go, just
three quick things--
I want to respect
your times, I know
we're at 12:00-- so please
do give us feedback.
The feedback link is going to
come up this screen shortly.
Two, if this is your first
time engaging or participating
or listening into
this conversation,
we especially thank you.
It takes some
boldness and courage
to step into this space.
We know it can be uncomfortable.
And that's OK.
It will always be
uncomfortable for a lot of us.
So we thank you for being here.
If you want to be more
involved, get in touch
with your ERG leads.
Sign up for a
race-announce for things
that you can do after
the Decoding Race series.
This is the ninth talk.
All the previous
talks are on YouTube.
This is going to be edited
and released on YouTube.
So until then, we ask
you to just hold off
on sharing anything
on social media.
Lastly, let's all again thank
our panelists and Lorrie
for moderating.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]